un bon soir nous sommes le mardi 16
février bienvenue dans le journal de la
rédaction de tv 60,18 voici les titres
de cette édition
trois jours après l attaque des
policiers ce conseil local de sécurité
ce matin en mairie de poissy la
municipalité réunissait les acteurs de
terrain pour échanger sur les incidents
et hier le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin est venu au commissariat
de la ville en soutien aux forces de
l'ordre
la détresse des locataires face à
l'insalubrité de leurs logements et
bâtiments plusieurs exemples dans les
yvelines dont celui de la résidence de
livrer à montigny le bretonneux les
habitants dénoncent le manque
d'entretien des parties communes
face à cette problématique aussi quels
sont les pouvoirs des élus face aux
bailleurs nous poserons la question à
notre invité laura merker maire de
montigny le bretonneux et puis rencontre
avec brahim burqa ce gérant de fast-food
offre des repas gratuits aux étudiants
et personnes dans le besoin à nantes la
jolie est la semaine dernière en pleine
période de grand froid son action a
permis la distribution de 180 burger
focus également tout à l'heure dans
cette édition sur l'association foresta
cleaning qui est à l'initiative de
jeunes disent linois elle organisé une
opération de ramassage de déchets
c'était dimanche en forêt à la celle
saint cloud
c'était samedi dernier une patrouille de
police était sérieusement en prise à
partie par une trentaine de personnes
dans le quartier de beauregard à poissy
une vidéo montrant les faits a suscité
nombre de réactions et trois jours après
les incidents la municipalité réunissait
ce matin en mairie les acteurs de
terrain pour un conseil local de
sécurité sur place représentant de
l'état associatif et forces de l'ordre
reportage c'était une réponse apportée à
l'attack des policiers par un groupe de
jeunes à poissy une réunion avec
l'ensemble des partenaires de la ville
s'est tenue ce mardi 16 février à
l'hôtel de ville
des représentants de l'état des forces
de police de l'éducation de l'emploi du
logement des associations et des acteurs
de terrain
la principale du collège jean jaurès
nous est que il était totalement
déscolarisés mais tenez vous bien
ils n'ont pas depuis leur entrée au
collège quasiment depuis la maternelle
avec une paupérisation intellectuelle
des familles
donc on le voit bien que c'est bien plus
profond que c'est le simple fait de
jeter un mortier ces jeunes ne se
dépensent plus ils vivent dans leurs
quartiers populaires en général dans
leurs familles souvent des familles
nombreuses donc dans des espaces qui
sont réduits c'est sûr que c'est pas une
norme en tant que tel pour autant est-ce
excusable que d'aller jeter des mortiers
à l'endroit des forces de police la
crise sanitaire n'arrange pas la
situation cette patrouille de police
prise à partie par des jeunes rappelle
l'urgence d'agir dans les quartiers
populaires notamment pour l'état à
travers ses compétences c'est la mise en
place avec le délégué du préfet par
exemple delà des sites de formation sur
la laïcité sur le fait religieux
c'est le travail qui est fait sur la
rénovation urbaine c'est à s'attendre
dead que l'on peut faire de nombreux
dispositifs sont aussi mises en place
par la commune en collaboration avec
d'autres collectivités
c'est le cas de la prévention
spécialisée du département des yvelines
avec l'association y fait
les éducateurs sont embauchés localement
pour encadrer des jeunes de quartiers
populaires sur le quartier de
saint-exupéry on eu bien moins de
problèmes parce que la prévention
spécialisée et est présente occupe
entre guillemets ces jeunes échangent
avec ces jeunes et de temps en temps
lorsque ces jeunes déborde et bien les
les recadre il ya un besoin
effectivement de communication pour
rappeler plus jamais les règles et
rappelait plus que jamais des règles ces
rencontres et rencontrer ces jeunes
le maire de poissy karl olive a d'ores
et déjà prévu de rencontrer les jeunes
du quartier beauregard d'ici la fin de
la semaine et hier gérald darmanin
effectué une visite surprise à poissy
déplacement au commissariat de la ville
en soutien aux policiers après les
incidents au quartier de beauregard
le ministre de l'intérieur a tenu à
mettre en garde contre tout laxisme face
à la délinquance et a annoncé des moyens
supplémentaires pour les forces de
l'ordre sur place écoutez le je suis
venu dire ici apprécie ce déplacement
était pour dire aux policiers qu'il faut
rien laisser passer en république et que
s'attaquent à des policiers c'est
s'attaquer à la république et le
ministère de l'intérieur soutient ces
policiers ces gendarmes des moyens
matériels supplémentaires
on va réfléchir aussi dans cette dans ce
coin des yvelines que je connais bien
également pour aider les élus dans leurs
interventions en caméra dit de
protection en effectif un matériel et
redire à l'ensemble de la population
française qui je sais soutient les
policiers que nous ne laisserons pas
passer le moindre laxisme envers ces
quelques uns qui embête une très grande
majorité d'entre nous ce mardi soir
aucune interpellation n'a encore eu lieu
mais une enquête a été ouverte pour
outrage et violences sur personne
dépositaire de l'autorité publique at on
appris du parquet de versailles
elle a été confiée à la sûreté urbaine
de conflans sainte honorine
c'est un sujet qui revient constamment
dans la presse locale l'insalubrité des
logements sociaux à plaisir et montigny
le bretonneux des résidents ont choisi
de se mobiliser une décision judiciaire
vient d'être rendue dans le premier cas
et dans l'autre et des échanges ont lieu
entre habitants et bailleurs le
reportage de mélanie poker et d'astrid
bergère des détritus des halls abîmé
cette situation a poussé marie-christine
motaze à s'engager m d'autres locataires
de livrer à montigny le bretonneux par
rapport aux charges que quand nous
demander et par rapport à l'entretien de
nos bâtiments par rapport aux services
qu'un bailleur nounou doigt parce qu'on
a des i
on a des devoirs cette payer notre loyer
mais aussi des droits c'est de vivre
dans un lieu propre
se sentir respecté et qui constataient
une amélioration mais on voit bien que
l'entretien courant n'est pas fait et ça
c'est comme c'est une obligation des
boyaux la résidence et gérés par le
bailleur céder ses habitats une réunion
s'est tenue lundi 15 février la société
de nettoyage est régulièrement mise en
demeure
ces derniers mois nous avons remarqué
une multiplication des actes
d'incivilité qui ont participé à la
satisfaction de nos locataires à ce
titre en fait nous avons envoyé des
courriers d'avertissements locataires
identifier nous sommes rapprochés des
services de la ville et de la police
pour obtenir une patrouille plus
régulière depuis le 4 février cdc met en
place des vacations d'agents de
médiation
onze caméras devraient être installées à
partir de mars 2021 livret est
réhabilité depuis deux ans à plaisir une
habitante du val hibou connaît des
conditions difficiles en janvier dernier
le tribunal de versailles reconnaît la
faute du bailleur les résidences
yvelines essonne quoi qu'elle fasse en
termes de ménage jamais
ne parviendra enlevé sept d'heures de
moisi parce que l'isolation des fenêtres
laissent à désirer parce qu'elles
évacuent les eaux usées de son
lave-linge dans son évier
j'espère sincèrement que effectivement
cette cette petite décision qui est
toute petite pierre à l'édifice pour la
lutte contre les appartements insalubres
permettront aux gens de se dire que bell
et d'ailleurs sont pas forcément
intouchable le bailleur prend acte de
cette décision de justice et ne souhaite
pas la commenter
une demande de relogement de la
résidante a été déposé selon la
fondation abbé pierre la france
compterait entre 450 mille six cent
mille logements indignes mais toujours
dans cette thématique laura merker est
avec nous par visioconférence bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le maire de montigny
le bretonneux également en premier
vice-président de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines en charge de
l'urbanisme et l'aménagement du
territoire déjà sur cette situation dont
on vient de parler à montigny le
bretonneux est ce que c'est un dossier
que vous suivez de près celui de cette
résidence de l'ivraie alors oui c'est un
dossier que nous suivons et nous
suivions depuis très longtemps puisque
nous avons beaucoup travaillé avec cette
amicale de locataires et avec la
présidente sur la réhabilitation de la
résidence et ce travail qui a permis
d'amener en 2018 au lancement des
travaux pour 6 millions d'euros sur la
résidence de livrer et du coup sur ce ce
dossier justement de l'insalubrité qui
est dénoncé dans les parties communes
par les habitants est ce que la mairie a
pu intervenir
est ce qu'elle est intervenue et de
quelle manière
surtout alors nous travaillons comme je
le disais avec l'amicale depuis de
nombreuses années et nous intervenons en
tant que tiers un tiers bienveillant
entre le l'amicale des locataires et le
bailleur pour essayer de trouver des
solutions parce qu'effectivement il y a
de la part du bailleur sans doute un
manque de réactivité au long cours sur
le travail d'entretien qui est amené
dans cette résidence
et puis comme l'indiquait la personne de
the hacker titre est responsable chez ce
bailleur social
nous avons aussi depuis un certain
nombre d'années à gérer des problèmes
d'incivilité qui génère des dégradations
et s'est dégradée
effectivement sont très très pénalisante
pour les habitants évidemment et et
rendent le travail aussi des entretiens
de la société assez compliqué est ce que
c'est la seule situation du genre
aujourd'hui à montigny le bretonneux ou
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres points de
vigilance
actuellement également sur des problèmes
de d'entretien de ce type il y a peut
être deux ou trois autres immeubles
bâtiments sociaux sur la ville où on
peut rencontrer quelques soucis mais
c'est vrai que le plus fort le plus
flagrant c'est sur livret justement face
à de telles situations vous parliez tout
à l'heure d'un rôle de tiers finalement
dans ce conflit qu'elle est quels sont
les moyens d'action du maire on sait que
les élus peuvent avoir des pouvoirs de
police spéciale en matière d'habitat est
ce qu'il ya des moyens d'action concret
dans ce genre de situation oui bien sûr
il ya des moyens on peut mettre en ont
peut être envie 9h le bailleur social
d'effectuer les travaux nécessaires dans
le cas de cette résidence encore une
fois l'âge et le jeune indiqua elias
millions d'euros de travaux qui ont été
engagés et il y à il y avait derrière
ces travaux de réhabilitation thermique
de ces bâtiments
l'engagement du bailleur à partir du
moment où les bâtiments seraient
rénovées d'être sur un suivi beaucoup
plus important keane qui n'était
auparavant sur cette résidence donc
c'est tout le travail que nous allons
mener avec l'amicale et avec le bailleur
c'est justement que le bailleur tienne
ses engagements et que dans les
prochains mois puisque les travaux de
réhabilitation arrive bientôt à leur
terme nous puissions avoir ce suivi
beaucoup plus sérieux beaucoup plus
intensifs au niveau de l'entretien des
parties communes
justement sur sur ce genre de question
les compétences sont souvent alors ce
qui concerne l'habitat transférer aussi
aux intercommunalités commencé justement
organisée avec saint quentin en yvelines
finalement qu'est ce qui est du ressort
de la commune et qu'est ce qui est du
ressort de l'agglomération sur cette
thématique de l'habitat l'agglomération
est davantage dans un rôle transversal
avec les différents bailleurs pour peser
auprès d'eux et leur demander les
interventions nécessaires
ensuite c'est vraiment le travail du
maire et de son équipe d'être aux côtés
de ses habitants et d'être
avec les bailleurs pour que les choses
puissent s'arranger c'est ce que nous
faisons tous que sur sur cette résidence
entre autres est un travail aussi avec
les services de l'état on imagine
notamment sur la question de
l'insalubrité ça il peut y avoir un
travail commun avec les services de
l'état avec le préfet des yvelines alors
nous n'avons pas été jusque là jusqu'à
présent puisque encore une fois nous
sommes sur des problématiques liées aux
os aux parties communes des logements et
comme vous avez pu le voir dans le
reportage on est beaucoup sur des
problèmes de dégradation donc en
revanche au niveau des logements
nous avons assez peu de problèmes
d'insalubrité il y avait des problèmes
auparavant dans l'est dans les logements
liées au vieillissement du bâtiment et
qui sont repris qui ont été repris lors
dans le cadre des travaux là aujourd'hui
nous savent davantage sur les parties
communes les escaliers les ascenseurs
les halls qui sont extrêmement dégradées
effectivement et pour lesquels il ya
vraiment besoin de faire beaucoup plus
attention de faire des passages beaucoup
plus régulier on a d'ailleurs eu encore
une réunion tout récemment avec le
bailleur et avec l'amicale séjour et le
bailleur s'est engagé à nouveau à faire
passer la société de nettoyage un rythme
beaucoup plus important une dernière
chose on revient au rôle des maires rôle
de l'agglomération en l'occurrence une
motion avait été adoptée en juin dernier
par l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines suspendant à l'époque les
garanties d'emprunt au bailleur social
valophis pour manquement à ses
obligations elle en était sur la commune
de trappes pour cette situation est ce
que c'est un moyen de pression efficace
juste en le le fait de pouvoir suspendre
ces garanties d'emprunt également auprès
des bailleurs
oui bien sûr si jamais nous avons
affaire à un bailleur qui qui fait la
sourde oreille et qui refusent de
répondre aux sollicitations des
habitants de des locataires dans ces cas
là la collectivité que ce soit la ville
où l'agglomération avec cet outil doit
peser évidemment pour mettre un maximum
de pression sur le bailleur et dans ces
cas-là ce type de suspension de garantie
est un excellent outil bien sûr merci
laurent mais requiert d'avoir été avec
nous je vous en prie maire de montigny
le bretonneux également premier vice
président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines en charge de
l'urbanisme et de l'aménagement du
territoire
dans l'actualité est toujours le
qu'ovide 19 et la part des variants qui
continue d'augmenter dans le nombre de
nouvelles contaminations selon le
laboratoire cerba 40 à 45% et des cas en
ile de france seraient liées aux
variants anglais du coronavirus
résultats des criblage effectué par la
structure dans les deux dernières
semaines elles les autres variantes sont
en hausse également ce brésilien et sud
africains représentent 4% des criblage
réalisé contre 2 5% la semaine dernière
paradoxalement les chiffres du colis de
19 dans les yvelines sont en recul sur
une semaine si l'on s'en réfère à ces
derniers chiffres et nette diminution du
taux d'incidence est à dire du nombre de
nouvelles contaminations pour 100000
habitants et baisse également du nombre
d'hospitalisations et du nombre de
réanimation six ans patients étaient
encore à l'hôpital hier lundi seul
indicateur en légère hausse le taux
d'occupation des lits de réanimation au
niveau francilien est depuis le début de
la crise sanitaire 1300 trois personnes
sont décédées du colis de 19 dans les
hôpitaux yvelinois pas que des choses
négatives bienheureusement la crise
sanitaire voit également à l'émergence
de solidarité d'initiatives solidaires
notamment celle de brahim bourkia
restaurateur installé à mantes la jolie
et depuis plusieurs semaines ils offrent
des repas aux personnes dans le besoin à
destination des étudiants mais pas
uniquement cet acte de solidarité a
largement été salué sur les réseaux
sociaux et dans sa commune
astrid berges heures pour le rencontrer
brahim burqa est le gérant d'un fast
food à mantes la jolie à l'étoile de fès
depuis son ouverture il ya quatre ans le
maître mot est la solidarité récemment
face à la détresse des étudiants le
restaurateur a décidé d'agir davantage
c'est à nous d'être solidaires entre
nous de se serrer les coudes et comme
j'ai dit les étudiants c'est une culture
de la france ils ont même pas se poser
la question qu'est ce qui doit manger
toi tu te dis papa tu étais tu envie de
devenir avocat mais l'état ils demandent
d'aller faire la queue pendant une heure
dans le froid pour avoir des pâtes et du
beurre c'est juste inconcevable en fait
pour obtenir un repas rien de plus
simple il suffit juste de venir et
d'indiquer que vous souhaite manger la
personne dans le besoin pourra donc
choisir entre un tacos une viande ou un
menu cheeseburgers
on dit je veux je suis étudiant je veux
manger on lui donne à manger on lui pose
pas plus de questions que ça on va pas
leur montée de demander un dossier pour
un prêt bancaire
s'ils viennent les récupérer à manger
repartent avec le sourire s'ils veulent
venir deux fois par jour une fois par
jour pendant je sais pas jusqu'à ce que
la situation s'arrange en fait il n'y a
pas de problème nous on est là pour ça
chez brel burqa cette générosité étaient
déjà présentes
il a mis en place dans son restaurant le
principe et iceberg est suspendu vous
prenez un menu vous payez un cheese ou
de houe autant que vous voulez en plus
nous ayons les nappes dans un carnet et
enfin qu'on arrive à 30 c quand ils vont
appeler l'association avant qu'il fasse
une maraude in prévient de la veille et
on les prépare tout simplement où les
emballe les meilleurs dessins cachot il
voulait distribuer sur paris la semaine
dernière avec le grand froid le
restaurateur a permis de distribuer 186
vainqueur à paris
d'un point de vue religieux culturel et
grâce à son éducation
cette solidarité lui semblait naturel on
a grandi dans un quartier défavorisé
qu'on sorte à l'école en sortie scolaire
quand il était petit pas vers sandwich à
la catalane ton pote il n'avait pas été
obligée partagé que lui tu avais un
paquet de chips il n'avait pas tu lui
donnes c'est comme ça toi quand tu avais
pas aussi on a et d autres qui venaient
on a droit du doigt cette ambiance-là
son action était largement saluée sur
les réseaux sociaux mais aussi par les
clients réguliers
je pense que c'est une bonne initiative
et on en a besoin en est temps qui
courent et ça fait du bien aussi de voir
que ça existe dans nos
dans nos quartiers dans nos villes et
que ce soit des étudiants ou des
personnes en difficulté on en a besoin
et ça fait du bien aujourd'hui brême
burqa espère que d'autres restaurateurs
prendront le relais de son initiative
partout en france
autre initiative cette fois ci pour
sauvegarder la nature à l'appel de
l'association forest clinique une
centaine de personnes s'est rassemblée
dimanche c'était à la celle saint cloud
l objectif libérer la forêt de ces
différents déchets les températures
n'ont pas refroidi les participants
mélanie poker la voix d'astrid bergère
après qu'est ce qui se passe ils vont où
les papiers yvon albanais samaran déjà
bien rempli leurs sacs poubelles la
mission du jour nettoyer autour de
l'étang de beauregard des bénévoles sont
venus ramasser des déchets en tous
genres à la celle saint cloud ce
dimanche après midi
d'abord ça nous fait sortir ça fait voir
un petit peu la végétation la nature et
puis à profiter d'une activité toutes
les deux ensemble et je trouve que c'est
bien aussi pour initier aux bons gestes
écologiques pour apprendre un petit peu
aux enfants que c'est important de ne
pas jeter de déchets on est un peu
désoeuvrés par rapport aux abords des
milieux naturels qu'on peut traverser et
qui sont jonchées de détritus et voilà
c'est pas comme ça qu'on aimerait voir
ces lieux je trouve ça important que
chacun participe à son petit niveau à
l'entretien de notre planète et
notamment des forêts qui sont envahis de
plastique et de sacs et de et de
détritus et chaussées important que la
jeune génération soit aussi là à
l'initiative l'association forest
cleaning lancé en septembre 2020 par de
jeunes illinois et compte à ce jour une
centaine de bénévoles
elle s'organise autour de trois missions
toutes les forêts bien sûr on doit les
nettoyer parce que si on ne nettoie pas
les forêts c'est vraiment les forêts
sont très très sale et c'est dans tous
les animaux meurent donc notre
association est là donc pour nettoyer
des forêts protéger les forêts et
sensibiliser les jeunes et les adultes à
ne plus jeter en forêt
l'association recherche des bénévoles
pour les accompagner lors de prochaines
actions et appellent aussi au doux les
fondateurs aimerait la développer dans
toute la france le sport on va parler de
voile l'information a été officialisée
ce mardi midi l'yvelinois louis burton
troisième du dernier vendée globe va
continuer l'aventuré avec durval et au
minimum jusqu'en 2026 autre annonce
importante le rachat du bateau
l'occitane en provence
mail tripon pour plus de 4 millions
d'euros un voilier de toute dernière
génération et qui a terminé 11e du
dernier vendée globe on écoute louis
burton lors de sa conférence de presse
les propos sélectionnés par michael et
demi d'euros cette vitesse ce concept
fait rêver et on est on est on est
persuadé que à la condition de savoir
préserver la structure lorsque lorsque
le lamer sera pas sera pas au rendez
vous pour attaquer on est persuadé que
ce sont des vins que c'est un bateau
du coup ce bureau vallée 3 qui est qui
nous permettra d'aller chercher des
podiums et peut-être en tout cas
j'espère ça va être mon objectif la
victoire
et puis le paris saint-germain retrouve
la ligue des champions ce mardi soir en
huitième de finale aller au camp nou
face au fc barcelone est dans le groupe
parisien pour affronter les catalans
l'entraîneur mauricio pochettino a
appelé également edouard michu
l'yvelinois de 17 ans est passé par les
clubs du chesnay de versailles avant
d'intégrer le paris saint-germain en
2016 international u17 le milieu de
terrain a signé son premier contrat
professionnel avec l'équipe de la
capitale en juillet dernier ce jusqu'en
2023 barcelone paris saint germain
coup d'envoi à 21h voilà c'est la fin de
ce journal merci de votre fidélité dans
un instant vous retrouverez justin
brasier à la tête de son émission le 7-8
culture belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]